And the Lord was with Joseph and he was a prosperous man and he was in the house
of his master.
The Egyptian and his master saw that the Lord was with him and the Lord made all
that he did to prosper in his hand.
So that's an echo of the idea that we encountered earlier about walking with
God.
Right.
So Adam walked with God before he ate the fruit with eve and then he wouldn't
walk with God and they had Noah walked with God and Abraham walked with God.
And so the idea is,
well that's that alignment with the highest ideal.
I think it's something like that.
And you know,
we could think about that as a metaphysical claim as well.
But I don't think it is.
I mean,
I've got thousands of letters now in the last year from people who have told me
that they were in a pit.
That's exactly right.
And that they decided that they were going to try to put their lives together
and that it worked.
And so that's really something,
you know,
and they write surprised.
It's like,
well,
I decided that I was going to work hard at what I was doing and I wasn't going
to lie any more than absolutely necessary.
I thought I'd give it a try for a few months,
you know,
and all sorts of good things started to happen.
To me,
it's like maybe that's how the world works now.
Obviously it doesn't work like that all the time.
Right.
Because you can get sliced off at the knees.
I mean there's an arbitrary element to existence that you can't wish away,
but that doesn't mean that there are,
it doesn't mean that there aren't bad strategies and good strategies.
So I do think that one of the most fundamental existential questions is like if
things aren't going well for you and your life is,
are you absolutely certain that you're doing absolutely everything you can to
put things in order?
Because if you're not,
then you shouldn't complain because you don't know to what degree you're
actually contributing or even causing the circumstance.
Now,
that's a very annoying thing to think,
and I'm not trying to blame the victim,
you know?
I know that people end up with lung cancer because they were exposed to
asbestos.
You know,
I'm not trying to,
although I also know too that if you have lung cancer because you've been
exposed to asbestos,
that can be a tragedy or it can be hell.
And to some degree,
that depends on how you conduct yourself.
So I mean,
I know that's pretty gloomy possibilities,
right?
But
so anyways,
so Joseph is a slave,
but it turns out that he's a,
he hasn't sacrifice the integrity of his character.
And so it turns out that being,
it turns out that he's not a slave.
It's just that everyone around him thinks he's a slave,
but he's not.
So that's pretty interesting.
He was a goodly person and well favored.
Well,
so he's a good guy and he's an impressive specimen as well.
This is pretty interesting given the current political climate,
I would say.
And it came to pass after these things that his master's wife cast her eyes upon
Joseph and she said,
lie with me.
That means that actually has two meanings.
Right?
Um,
but he refused
and said unto his master's wife,
behold,
my master
does not know what's with me in the house and he's committed all that he has to
my hand.
There is no one greater in this house than I neither has.
He kept back anything from me,
but you because you are his wife.
How then can I do this great wickedness,
wickedness,
and sin against God.
And it came to pass as she speak to Joseph Day by day that he harkened not unto
her to lie by her or be with her.
It's being sexually harassed.
Joseph.
And it came to pass.
Well,
it's right,
it's right.
I mean,
look,
look at the painting.
And it came to pass about this time that Joseph went into the house to do his
business and there was none of the men of the house they're within.
And she caught him by his garment saying,
lie with me.
And he left his garment in her hand and fled and got him out.
So that's kind of embarrassing for poor Joseph,
I would say.
And a bit on the suspicious side.
And it came to pass when she saw that he had left his garment in her hand and
was fled forth,
that she called unto the men of her house and spake unto them.
See,
see,
he has brought into Hebrew to mark us.
He came in unto me,
lie with me,
and I cried with a loud voice.
So what is it Hell hath no fury like a woman scorned?
That's the proper commentary on that.
And it came to pass when he heard that,
I lifted up my voice and cried that he left his garment with me and fled and got
himself out and it came to pass when his master heard the words of his wife.
So that's the Faro,
which he spake unto him,
saying,
after this manner,
did thy servant to me,
his wrath was kindled and Joseph's master took him and put him in prison.
A place where the king's prisoners were,
was,
were bound,
and he was there in the prison.
Well,
that sort of sucks.
It's like first his brothers betray him and throw him in a pit and then he gets
made a slave,
which is probably better than being in the pet.
And then he becomes sort of like king slave.
So that's working out pretty well and now someone lies about him,
he gets betrayed again and now it's into the prison with them.
And so it's this,
it's this again,
right?
It's the same thing.
It's [inaudible] with the Rock and then down in its order,
chaos,
order,
chaos.
And then you have to think,
well,
are you the order?
Are you the chaos or you the thing that's moving between them because that's the
right thing to be.
Because otherwise you're just ordering.
That's a really bad idea.
Or you're just chaos and that's a really bad idea.
You can be the thing that's dynamically mediating between them and that's what
he's doing.
But the Lord was with Joseph and showed him mercy and gave him favor in the
sight of the keeper of the prison.
That's no easy thing to do,
I would think.
You know,
it's like you're thrown in prison and now the jailer likes you.
Now.
How exactly are you going to manage that as much good thing to think about
because you might think,
well,
if you were really in dire straits,
how is it that you should conduct yourself so that you have the highest
probability of having things work out?
And it's not saying,
well,
Joseph took over the thumb screw,
you know,
and started using that on the other prisoners that that's not the indication
here at all.
It's that he's doing something.
He's acting like a person who isn't a prisoner,
even though he's in the prison,
just like he was acting like someone who wasn't a slave when he was a slave.
And so
it makes you wonder who you can be despite the fact that other people think that
you're whatever you appear to be.